hey guys this is video with maxtec and
welcome to my
ultimate gaming review of the m1
macbook pro now if you're wondering why
i'm calling this the ultimate gaming
review
well that's because i'm going all out
on the games as you can see right here i
have a bunch of games loaded up
and i'm going to be playing games using
four different methods
the first one is playing native arm
games for mac the second method is
playing the older x86
mac games using rosetta 2. the third way
is playing ios and ipad games
using side loading and i'm going to show
you guys how to do that
and finally the fourth way is playing
windows
games using crossover now i don't know
if you guys remember this but way back
in july
i made a video titled apple silicon is
bringing triple-a gaming to the mac
now when i made that video i meant that
after a year or two we would finally
have
aaa gaming maybe even next year with the
expected m1x chip that i made a video
about
definitely check out that video because
that's going to give you much more
graphics performance
but i did not mean the very first
apple silicon max are going to bring aaa
gaming but to everyone's surprise
after only about three weeks people are
already playing
aaa games on this machine in fact a
whole community has been created
on reddit mac gaming of people playing
aaa games on the m1 max and a little bit
later in this video i'm going to be
playing diablo 3
i'm going to play cs go i'm going to
play even witcher 3
on this m1 macbook pro so as you guys
can see i have an xbox controller for
controller games
and i have an mx master mouse to play
those
aaa games so let's go ahead and see if i
was right
or i was wrong all right the first thing
i'm going to show you
is multi-craft it's one of the few games
that's actually been updated for apple
silicon and it's running
natively so one of the other games is
world of warcraft but i don't really
want to play that i don't play that and
it's a massive
massive download by the way do not buy a
256 gig
model of one of these m1 max especially
if you're trying to game
because you really can't load up that
much games we have a 512 gig model right
here
it also has 16 gigs of memory but in
reality for gaming you only need the 8
gig model because
if you guys watched our intel xps versus
m1 macbook pro video
you'll know that apple's unified memory
is extremely efficient so
8 gigs on the m1 is pretty similar to
16 gigs on older intel max
but anyway here we are in multicraft
it's basically a minecraft clone
it's running natively for apple silicon
and
as you guys can see it's running
perfectly smooth like
perfect 60fps our cameras by the way are
set to 4k60
and there you go i'm using my mx master
mouse and
honestly i don't play minecraft i don't
care for it but here you go
playing perfectly smooth this game is
extremely efficient we're running with
10
cpu usage 43 on the gpu
the chip is at 42 degrees celsius it's
incredibly cool
and as you can see the fan is off as
well so these apple silicon games are
gonna run
very well of course this is a low end
game we're going to get into the higher
end games in just a second now i want to
get out of this game and i want to move
on to showing you guys
some iphone and ipad games now the way
you do that is you go to the app store
you search for a game and you have this
little section right here iphone and
ipad
apps and boom there you go i'm going to
show you guys dark
raider it's just a simple low end rpg
game let's open it up now what's cool is
that you can hit the full screen mode
bam obviously it doesn't cover the
entire display because ipads have a more
square-ish
aspect ratio but as you can see i have
my controller right here the xbox
controller
and it's working perfectly fine
the fans are still not running so it's
really awesome to see controller support
working on the mac it's only been three
weeks since we've got our hands on these
so this is
really really exciting now i want to
show you guys some of the apps that i
side
loaded and to do that i downloaded
imazing so this is a paid app but you
can get a two week trial as you can see
boom continue trial now what you do is
you connect your ipad or your iphone
and after you do that you go to manage
apps it's going to have you log into
your icloud account and then you can see
all of your apps now what you do
is you right click on something and you
click download
to library you can see it downloading
right over here
there you go it just finished you right
click on it you click
export ipa and i'm going to throw it
into the applications folder
go to applications find that
game double click on it it's installing
boom there you go open it up
and it's playing battlelands royale
we just installed it just like that
that's how easy it is
for a game like this this is not optimal
because
this does not support controllers and
that really really really sucks
but i am going to show you guys some
controller games here in a second
oh definitely not a good experience like
this let's go ahead and close that
and let's choose a better game here's an
rpg game
grim valor that has controller support
as you can see
by the way guys thanks for helping us
finally reach 500k
subs we appreciate each and every one of
you
so here you guys can see i mean this is
pretty awesome
controller supports working very well
this is kind of like a side scroller
style rpg
oh that's fun now i want to show you
guys some more simple games some more
popular games
for example clash royale works perfectly
as you can see it's this
small little window but i can go full
screen and for this game you just use
the track pad
just like that you can just battle it
logs you in using game center which is
great
and i'm about to play with the real
opponent apple did an excellent job
with this automatic touch translation
feature this is
this is awesome so if you want to play
simple games like this
i mean you can no issues at all playing
a game like this
anyway i showed you guys clash royale
let's do another one let's see
just like that it's running you know
what let's try multiple
king of thieves let's open that up right
here
multiple games running at the same time
this is kind of funny all right look at
that you just switch over
you switch your mouse over and it works
so easily i mean i'm so impressed
brawl stars let's open that up too
put it over here why not brawl holla
let's do that one too right over here
playing clash of clans look at that what
about this let's
find a match here why not there you go
oh
boom all right i got that how about
let's play brawl stars
there you go searching for players
logged in how about this game
look this game supports controller
support online play
free for all let's go look at this
actually let's
let's go full screen on this hey it
looks like it canceled out the audio
from the other games even though they're
playing in the background
dude i don't want this oh you see that
get out of here bro this is pretty fun
i've
gotta admit all right anyway let's exit
out of that there you go we have our
games running
look at that cpu using what 39 23
44 the fan is completely off
chilling at 45 degrees celsius playing
all of these four games
at the same time just like that you exit
out of them
i mean this is this is great let's spice
it up a little bit
playing a fps shooter game with
controller support let's go ahead and
full screen it there you go
i mean this works so well this is
actually a pretty
decent game and it's running
perfectly whoa bro
grunts i'm impressed how well this works
on this macbook pro and you get a nice
big display
full screen mode now i did download
call of duty mobile but unfortunately
as you're going to see in just a second
i don't think controller support is
working
just yet wait a minute it's working
controller support is working no way
it's working on call of duty mobile
all right let's do this oh my goodness
there you go and just like that
everything's working
don't play with your main account if
you're gonna try this out
because you can very easily get banned i
don't know why they would ban you but
triple q nice there you guys go look the
fan is still off i just played call of
duty mobile
no issues 42 degrees celsius now let's
finally move on to the
third method of gaming which is old
intel x86 mac games
let's start out with league of legends
there you go we have the league of
legends client open
let's go ahead and hit play and do a
blind pick
summoner's rift now what's very
interesting is that i just have the
client open we're sitting at
99 gpu usage all right we're in game i'm
gonna go ahead and max out the
resolution 2560 by 1600
that's native and let's go ahead and
just max everything out
all right we got about 89 fps 79 fps i
don't know if you guys can see that up
there the fps
ticker 88 is that yasuo okay that's
yasuo
anyway i mean 70 fps right there 69 fps
guys i maxed out the graphics
completely maxed out graphics i mean
this is awesome this is great league of
legends running
perfectly under rosetta you don't even
have to wait for it to get updated i
mean come on
oh no i died again 72 fps right there
74 fps right there 81 so obviously this
runs
incredibly well it doesn't even need to
be updated
no issues at all playing league of
legends
sorry guys my team but i gotta move on
by the way i just finished league of
legends the fan is still off
no sweat for league so here i am in
steam
for the mac i'm about to play cs
go under rosetta here we are in cs go
the lobby is running perfectly let's
play some arms race
here we are so far playing perfectly
smooth
no issues at all come on man i don't
know why
we have bots in here
of course this is a pretty simple and
easy game but the truth is that
a lot of people play cs go
and a lot of people play league of
legends they're very popular games
and right here on the m1 max
no issues at all playing perfectly
smooth
before you couldn't do this with the
base model macbook pro
taking a look at the settings we're at
1680 by 1050 resolution
not bad just because i'm curious let's
do native it seems like the fps counter
is not working but here we are playing
at native res
and we are no longer playing at 60 fps
maybe 40 fps is what we're getting right
now
it's definitely not as smooth as it was
before this might be playable
i'd probably turn it down a bit which i
will here in a second
how about i don't know 1650 by 1050
again that was
that was pretty decent back at the lower
res and i mean look at this
everyone runs faster with a knife
got him
[Music]
gotcha gotcha and this is not even
native performance
under rosetta who would have thought huh
who
would have thought anyway that cs go
let's go ahead and look at our temps
back to the finder we're at 92 degrees
celsius
on the cpu we're at around 1500 rpm on
the fan
not too bad i mean the fan really wasn't
blowing it was
basically at idle now let's get into the
next game
diablo 3 running under rosetta
and this is definitely a triple a
game here we are in the menus
everything's working very smooth and
let's
get back into the game before i show you
the crazy performance check out these
graphics options
native resolution 2560 by 1600
we're capped to 60 fps shadows are on
medium textures on high physics high
clutter high anti-aliasing full screen
there you go
there are the settings you guys seen
this
look how smooth that is i mean i'm not
noticing any issues this is native
resolution
under rosetta oh get out of here
conjurer of death dude you're screwed
bro that was easy
you could not do this with a 13-inch
macbook
in the past never imagine what's gonna
happen next year when the m1x
inch comes out with potentially double
the graphics performance
with this running this well on the m1
i am blown away i am not noticing
any stuttering any dropped frames in
this game
now with that i want to move on to the
most exciting way to play
games the fourth way this is using
crossover
to play windows games now this is a paid
app
but you get a free 14-day trial of the
full version
so let's move on with this trial now
to play games like this all you do is
you click
install a windows application you type
in steam
you install steam and then after that
you install
two more things you install directx for
modern games
you click that and you do it within the
steam
bottle make sure to do that right after
that you find
dx vk and you install that
also within the steam bottle and then
after you have those installed you're
going to click over here on the bottles
you're going to go down to steam you
right click on it
go to settings and then enable just like
i did
dxvk back end for d3
direct 11. once you enable that you're
good to go
let's start steam and as you guys can
see right here we have the
windows version of steam running
so if we look through my library when
you click on games that are meant for
windows
you can actually install them now not
all of them are going to play
a couple of games that i tried didn't
work but here i have some games
that are gonna work as you guys can see
i have team fortress 2 installed
i have the witcher 3 which we're going
to test
in just a minute because it's totally
insane and finally
i installed a classic one of my most
favorite games from my childhood final
fantasy 10 bringing back that nostalgia
let's see if it runs so here we have the
launcher
i never played x2 because i thought it
was kind of weird
i play final fantasy 10 so here i have
the resolution i try to add a bunch of
different ones for some reason it
doesn't run at higher resolutions
it's kind of weird but i have the
settings set right here
quality on low unfortunately that's the
only way i got it to run
let's test it out all right here we are
guys final fantasy 10. i had to mess
with the settings to get it to run
here we are in full screen you can hear
this
nostalgic music and for some reason
the fps that the steam counter is
showing us is really bad
7 fps but it's working let's test this
out
do i use space well oh can i get it can
i get it
boom there we go look at that 18 fps so
it's not the best quality for some
reason the resolution isn't that great
in this game
but we are playing this right here is
probably the worst
part of the game oh it's horrible
absolutely horrible part of the game i
mean hey it's playable
we're playing not the best fps not super
smooth now since the fps we're getting
is not that great let's go ahead and
test out
a different game within crossover all
right that was weird it just crashed and
restarted i'm not sure
why that happened i just closed down
final fantasy
so there is definitely more
optimizations to be done within
crossover
and with the whole gaming and emulating
in general but
it restarted pretty quickly there
alright we're back into steam and now
let's try out
team fortress 2. here in the lobby it
says we're getting over 100 fps we'll
see how that changes
as we actually start playing all right
here we are and it feels
decently smooth so far 52
37 fps just dropped 31
so you don't get that good of
performance it seems like in
crossover so far
54 75 that's a little better but i am
having some weird drop
frames every now and then yeah this is a
little bit weird
well i was able to kill that guy
definitely drop frames going on
looks like we're i mean we just hit 100
fps doesn't make sense
we are dropping down quite low every now
and then
get out of here bro there you go 31 fps
definitely drops not a very good
gaming experience
what's up bro it seems like when i'm not
fighting someone
it's decent but as soon as i see someone
gets really bad really quick
so there you go we're playing tft the
graphics quality
isn't that good either we're sitting at
1440 by 900 resolution and the quality's
a lot of it is set to low so i don't
know what's going on
it's probably because it's not that
modern of a game it's using directx
9. all right witcher 3 right here this
is definitely
a aaa title let's run it using crossover
let's see the performance that we get
here we are which are three
unfortunately the fps counter is not
working but we're gonna go ahead and
continue
all right here we are in witcher 3 guys
look at that this is definitely much
more smooth i
am getting some frame drops decent
performance
playing witcher 3 this is a aaa title
we're playing this with decent
performance using crossover
yeah that's impressive so it seems like
when you're using crossover
the more modern games like this
run much much better than games like
final fantasy and team fortress 2
that are very very old games guys i was
running that
at native resolution 2560
by 1600 i turned off and turned down a
bunch of the other settings
but native resolution
playing that let's turn it down a little
bit to see if we get better
performance let's do 1650 by 1050.
all right there you go i think it's
definitely more smooth
definitely feels more smooth who would
have thought that apple's very first
apple silicon mac the m1 ship would be
able to play
games like witcher 3. all right let's
test out the
uh battle performance with these
creepy dudes oh crap these guys are
strong unfortunately i don't know how to
play this game
am i gonna die here oh yeah i'm so dead
anyway i mean it was performing well
we're not really getting any stuttering
we're not getting any performance issues
playing witcher 3 just because i'm
curious i'm going to check out
the performance we're at 92 degrees
celsius
4 000 rpms on the fans there you go if i
get close
i can definitely hear them that's what
it took 100 gpu load
35 cpu load to get it hot
playing witcher 3 after playing all of
those games the iphone games the ipad
games
call of duty mobile using the controller
really nice controller support
playing under rosetta league of legends
perfectly smooth
diablo 3 perfectly smooth cs go decent
performance
even crossover playing old nostalgia
games like final fantasy
playing witcher 3 with really impressive
performance
i have to say that apple silicon the m1
chip
is the best thing that has happened to
the mac in terms of gaming this is a
gaming revolution it's only been
three weeks we're already seeing
developers updating their games for
native apple silicon support
and without that we're getting really
good performance under rosetta which
nobody was expecting this is shocking
that
a laptop like this the 13-inch
is getting good performance like this in
gaming so to answer the original
question
is the m1 macbook pro good for gaming i
have to say
yes this is performance on par with the
best 16 inch macbook pro
and when we see next year's m1x chip
that is just going to be on a whole
nother level and it's going to take
gaming on the mac to a higher
level is just going to be so impressive
and even this
is super impressive and the last thing i
want to mention is that it's only been
three weeks and developers are already
working on getting native
support developers are working to get
crossover updated to support
more games rosetta's being upgraded as
well
so with all that said i have to say that
i couldn't be happier
with the m1 macbook pro for gaming so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this ultimate
gaming review
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe because we're
trying to reach
650k subscribers before the end of march
so please help us with that
definitely check out a couple of those
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you
in the next video